to my mind the new yorker whatever
experiments occur the most interesting
experiments that occur there any radical
departures or in the writing to me
that's that's where the excitement is
will we be on an iPad absolutely i hope
we look right there and if people want
to read us they're fantastic we're
working very hard to do that just as we
worked hard to have a website that's
worthy of the name my idea of the new
yorker as long as i'm there is that we
are not going to change who we are no
matter what the delivery systems are no
matter what the means of reading us we
are about reading we're about long-form
journalism analysis humor fiction poetry
a sense of delight a sense of
seriousness when it's when it's
appropriate if we start giving away
these core things because in the short
term we somehow think well you know
actually three paragraph long pieces the
hell with George Packer doing fifteen
thousand words on American politics or
sy Hersh writing extremely naughty piece
about some aspect of intelligence or
sending somebody to Afghanistan three
times to get the story or unleashing
David grand for six months to get a
death-penalty piece or what have you in
other words what I think of as the core
of the New Yorker I'm not here to get
rid of fiction because I think that not
a hundred percent of the people read it
I don't care about that I I think this
is a formula that took a long long time
to develop and people want what we do
they may want to read it in it on a
different device soon enough and I it's
not coming it's here most of our readers
at this point still think the best
technology for reading it is on print
those proportions will inevitably change
how much they will change I don't know
I'm not a media fortune-teller I'm not a
god forbid a media consultant I'm here
to edit the magazine and to be as nimble
as we can be in terms of this period of
technological challenge and interest and
it's potentially will bring us more and
more readers but I promise you that no
matter what form you read it
it's it the intent is to be true true to
who we are
not at all and I you
I have a lot of respect for Tina I
reject any notion that somehow Tina was
completely out of the mainstream of what
the new yorker wanted to do I think she
brought a lot to it and you know a lot
of what the visual aspect of the New
Yorkers do to her innovation she hired a
lot of people that are still there
they're very important to the New Yorker
but any any website that's built around
news and what's going on now in five
minutes later and aggregating and
churning what's going on in them in the
moment is inevitably going to get a
higher traffic certainly the New York
Times calm is going to get a hell of a
lot more traffic because it's a daily
newspaper that's now not just daily but
is is trying to keep up to the news but
in the moment this is not what we're
equipped to do that's not what we are
built for I've been at a newspaper I
spent ten years of my life at the
Washington Post I know what that's about
I'm not going to at the Washington Post
have a fake AP and we're not going to
spend all our energies in aggregating
from all over the Internet we're there
to create the core long-form journalism
that may get aggregated by somebody else
it may get chopped up into little bits
and talked about on other websites I can
live with that easily people want what
we do and the more time goes by the more
this technological revolution happens
there's not more of this there's not
more depth there's not more deep
analysis in fact there's arguably less
of it because it's expensive to do it's
hard to do so you know my hats off to a
lot of websites i read them but this is
what I want to be doing at The New
Yorker and that's what my colleagues
want to be doing
what's interesting to me is that as
unnerving as any transformative period
is and there's clearly you can't give
young writers or journalists the advice
that you used to 20 years ago you know
go to the Concord Monitor and and and
work in a small newspaper and then find
your way to a larger one that that model
it's almost irresponsible to think
that's the singular piece of advice that
kind of you know middle-aged guy like me
should give to somebody that's 23 it's
obscenely wrong in fact the paths into
journalism are now more various they
were also more unnerving because where
you get paid for it and get paid
decently for it are tougher to find
there's no doubt that some in some ways
it's easier to get in and easier to get
noticed because the internet is so
democratic that way but to earn a living
is getting more complicated and you know
I'm determined to pay people and pay
people well talented people well it's
just so long as we can sustain a model
or even a shifting model so that we can
do that that's a that's that that's the
idea that's the trick do I see young
people every bit as energetic and is
intelligent and dirt and with the urge
to express themselves you bet I do and
even at some length not everybody is
interested in making a life as a as a
blogger not everybody thinks the way the
best means of self-expression or even
information or writing is to have 40
disparate thoughts in the course of a
day some of that is interesting some of
I think is really not there are lots of
people that I talk to in their 20s that
are really interested in doing the very
same thing in terms of long-form
journalism that people twice their age
and three times their age have been
doing for a long time it is thrilling
when we have the chance to hire new
writers who are young and who are
developing I mean and and getting better
all the time and are totally obsessed
with what they're doing somebody like
Lauren Collins or Ari levy or Khalifa
sauna at The New Yorker who are
relatively recent hires are it's just
fantastic and it's also it and it's
really fantastic
stick to see one piece be better than
the last one and the next piece be even
better I mean because they're there in
that they're just in the zone of growing
all the time it's fantastic it's really
thrilling as an editor